hello everyone if you enjoy games of
mikhail tal Rasha Najeh medina and maybe
rudolf Spielman then i definitely
recommend you check out some games by a
dragon without a mirror which this game
was played in 1971 it was the year of le
meter which got his international master
title only a year later in 1972 he got
his Grandmaster title and he was a
definitely a strong player he won the
Yugoslav championship three times and he
competed in two Interzone all
tournaments he never really managed to
qualify for the candidates but that
doesn't really matter as a really mirror
which is legacy isn't in how many points
he won or how solid games he played it's
in it's in the beauty of the games he
played and the magic he created over the
board and this game he's playing against
the creation international master
Vladimir buckle and he has the white
pieces and it's a it's a pretty amazing
game you'll see
and the variation they play actually
bears the name of the valley mirror
which the valley mirror which attack so
let's see a valley meter which is white
and he plays efore we have c5 the
Sicilian defense Knight to f3 d6 d4 see
captor son d4 Knight captures on d4
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 all standard
Knight to c6 and now the Fischer
favorite Bishop to c4 or the source and
variation we have e 6 the Shiva ningún
and Bishop to e3
we have Bishop to e7 and now the move
that well
announces the value meter which attack
Queen to e 2 preparing queenside castle
we have a 6 and now the queenside castle
and quinta c7 and Bishop to b3 we are
castles bye boo Cal and g4 and now this
announces a trademark value meter which
move but you'll see what I mean
buko goes for Knight to d7 not allowing
g5 with tempo and now comes the value
meter which move Knight to f5 and the
limiter which played this Knight
sacrifice so many times that well this
move I don't think if it officially
his name but definitely should so what
do you do with the night here well you
can't really just leave it there an f5
it's it's an extremely powerful piece if
you just leave it there so buckle
captures that we have in captures on f5
and well you don't want to capture it
with the Jeep on you know to open up a G
file but there is a better in-between
move here Knight to d5 gaining this
beautiful d5 square for night and also
this comes with a temple on the Queen so
Queen to d8 and now G captures an f5
opening up the G file and okay bucola is
up a piece and he plays Knight to a5 he
wants to exchange even more pieces and
especially this strong bishop on be
three millimeters goes for Knight
captures an e7 Queen captures on e7 and
now Bishop to d5 preserving the slide
squirt Bishop King to h8 unpinning rook
H to g1 now assuming to open G file and
Knight to f6
you can't preserve the light square
bishop anymore so the limiter which gets
another idea
he plays Queen to f3 book of captures
the bishop of course he wants to
exchange pieces very much nightly after
Sunday 5 rook captures on d5 this comes
with a temple on this night on a5 and
Knight to c4 why not to go for more
exchanges or preparing to grab the
bishop on e3 and here are well of a
valley meter which is still down a piece
which makes his idea even more brilliant
he plays f6 we have Queen captures on f6
so forcing a trade of Queens being a
piece down Queen captures on f6g
captures on f6 and now Bishop to d4 with
a pretty straightforward idea of course
of Bishop captures on f6 with checkmate
so this has to be stopped Knight to e5
and F for kicking the night away so
night night goes to d7 only square to
protect the f6 he can't really go to g4
because h3 win wins the game immediately
so rook captures and e6 again with a
pretty straightforward idea the ideas
caPSURE snide only seven and then well
the same idea Bishop captures pawn and
f6 with checkmate
and we have worked the g8 now if rook
captures Knight rook captures rook with
Czech rope to be one of course the
voltmeter which doesn't want to exchange
rooks and we have rook to e8 now making
room for the King on g8 and also
attacking this efore pawn and
development which plays f5 and you'll
see the idea of this f5 move which
really really makes you think how far
villa mirror which saw this game go rook
captures on e4 and rook to g1 again with
the threat of knife of Bishop of rook
captures on d7 and Bishop captures on f6
and here we have h5 making room for the
king and h7 and what do you play here
well availa meter which goes for rook to
g5 and it doesn't seem that this rook to
g5 i mean of course you can't capture
the rook this pawn is pinned and it
doesn't really look like White has
anything here but this rook the g5 is
actually a deep and a devious trap and
the only way to avoid the trap is to
play King to h7 but book all didn't see
this and he played a rock to g4 but I
just want to point out that you can't
really give up some material with rook
captures on d4 you know just you know
giving up some material to get back into
the game because after rocky at first
and before you get rook captures and h5
would check king g6 and now rook
captures on d4 and okay it seems like
bucco still has a rook and two pieces
for the rook but it only seems like that
because black can't really develop any
of his pieces if he tries something like
b5 he gets rocked to g4 with check King
f8 rocket check King a7 and I rock the
g8 attacking this Bishop on c8 and after
a night to b6 Rock to d8 and well you
can't defend
rook to e8 checkmate you have to play
something like Bishop to d7 and then
Brooke captors on a a knife captures and
rook captures and white is completely
winning
so okay now that we see that this is out
of the question
bucola played rook to g4 and here Villa
meter which has a crushing attack
he plays rook captures on f6 and in this
position well black can simply resign
the game because he doesn't have
anything to do you can't capture this
rook on f6 and you can't capture this
rope in g5 if you capture the rook on g5
you get rook to h6 with a double check
from the rook and the bishop King to g8
only move and Rock the h8 with checkmate
and if after rook to f6 you try maybe
capture this rook on f6 you get Bishop
captures on f6 with check King to h7
only move and now rook captures on h5
and now you see the beauty of this f5
move it's guarding g6 the King can't go
to g6 King has to go to g8 and now again
rook to 88 checkmate so I have to rope
to a6 book I'll try it one more idea
rook the g1 with Czech and this is a
pretty desperate attempt to but you know
you're still a piece up you do have to
try something
Vella meter which can even capture the
rook capturing it rook is still
completely winning for white but a villa
meter which ends the game in a brilliant
fashion he plays kink to b2 and still
black can't capture either of the rooks
he tries rocked g2 with check villa
meter which is just plays the simple
King to e3 and in this position allowed
me to book I resigned at the game as he
doesn't have any more checks and well
whatever he plays he's getting a check
made it in in the next couple of moves
so yeah I do hope you enjoyed this game
and for those of you who are only
hearing about the building marriage for
the first time I suggest you check out
some of its other games I will probably
I will probably show some of his other
games as well as when I first started
learning about chess I rather read about
him and some of the checks books the
chess books I had and like with Dahle I
was really fascinated with his style so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon